perché è una persona seria si appella a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fatti j
lui è il mio caso è oggi stiamo in un
blog sta mettendo che sibat i ragazzi
perché non so se ve lo ricordate
avevo promesso che avrei fatto un video
con i baffi perché faccio queste
promesse belle quelli di ragazzi e come
in tutta la mia mascolinità che non ho
mai acquisito nella mia vita prima di
cominciare agazzi cose devi partire la
forma della settimana è stata vinta la
giulia che ha fatto sta fanatici e bella
però mancano i baffi colore qual è la
prima cosa mi sono ritrovato allora io
su facebook e l'altro giorno è su
instagram messo statuto quale sarebbe
ragazzi l'ho fatto l'ho fatto quando ho
fatto il pupazzo di neve perché ho fatto
un pupazzo io so fare i pupazzi di neve
non l'avreste mai detto dopo un paio di
giorni ma è arrivata questa perché
perché dimmelo ti prego hassan dalle
news ragazzi volevo annunciare lo sapete
già tutti ma che l'avete credo visto
abbiamo finito ha diviso le shaun è
durato secoli credo di averlo iniziato
quando ancora dovranno inventare la
ruota credo prova dolore mi chiaramida
un trono scusa mi davano troppo fastidio
abbiate pazienza sembra un tasso
concludo poco le news perché non c'è un
cazzola dire stavolta però vi siete solo
stavolta vi siete salvati per gli voleva
dire una cosa prima dello scarto dei
pacchi ne fa vi risponde quando ricevuto
il golden button di youtube che sarebbe
una targa che youtube stessa si occupa
di gara youtuber che hanno superato
milioni di iscritti
molti di voi magari hanno visto questa
che è veramente la targa che youtube da
a chi ha superato i 100mila iscritti
perché la danno molto più spesso
intitolato in inglese fa troppo figo ci
sono qui ricordate i coriandoli di
quella volta lì robottone un esplosivo
boom
cristo ce l'ha scritto non esplosivo
porca [ __ ] orca la eva dopo un mese
porca [ __ ] trovo ancora si coriandoli
per caso i ragazzi sto discorso è
partito perché molti di voi mi hanno
chiesto una familista e la targa questa
qui da 100mila iscritti dove cazzo hai
messo a quella da un milione in realtà
ragazzi con la targa me l'avevano data
al games week
a milano è talmente grossa che io non
potevo portarmela casa perché la
veramente grossa e pesava un casino un
uomo solo non sarebbe mai riuscito a
porta forse neanche protesta non si
sarebbe riuscito e io non sono proprio
blog lei ne prova beh l'ho ricevuta casa
praticamente soltanto adesso volevo
farvela vedere perché molti di voi mi
chiedo ma favino e calze lega non ce
l'avevo marco io e quindi ragazzi se
questa vi sembra grande come come targa
porchio tra i ragazzi pesa più di me
sicuro vabbè è questa qua e c'è scritto
un milione pronuncia faccia solo se
riesco a fare c'è scritto milione a c'è
scritto mio
comunque queste perché molti gli vengono
chieste dalla targa da un milione per
non l'avevo hai fatta vedere perché non
ce l'avevo manco io lì ci siamo noi non
io c'è scritto un milione ci siamo tutti
quanti per me appunto simbolicamente a
un valore incredibile re e vi ringrazio
di cuore non trovo mai le parole quindi
smetto di dirk agate che possono
risultare banali pro veramente grazie
grazie
mi è mancata la voce alla fine ho
rovinato questo momento volemose bene
con la mia voce di merda però anche
ragazzi dopo tutte queste belle cose
dopo tutti questi coriandoli che sono
ancora sulla scrivania dopo un mese dal
video dove sono esplosi [ __ ] direi
che possiamo passare allo scarpeccio dei
pac dopo aver sollevato la targa mica mi
sembra tutto leggero non è possibile
comunque che il palco del giorno direi
che questo perché c'è il fiocco cioè io
io vorrei veramente chiedergli perché il
fiocco giallo per l'ultimo ragazzi e
ripartire al più piccolo perché faccio
sempre così vediamo che cazzo finché un
regalo di natale un regalo di natale
anche se siamo al 10 di gennaio che figo
scritto e non è che potresti contattarvi
su questo numero e darmi il tuo a ti
scongiuro con dei cuoricini
ok quale numero di sei dimenticato di
scrivere lui prova bene ok adesso sono
curioso di vedere il regalo perchè
perchè se voi pensate che i ragazzi
chiedono le playstation le minimoto no
un carbone non avete capito niente dalla
vita ci vuole lo kitty's sempre una
ghirlanda rosa grazie lo casi così
preferivo hello kitty ma chi è bella
[Musica]
è una barbie con le tette di fuori è il
pensiero che conta lo so ma porca [ __ ]
che è figo che è mai ace capelli così da
schifo davvero se anche peggio chi è
mario con un bernoccolo mica hai preso
un macigno in testa zero mi avete
regalato un iphone troll un iphone tron
e il vento queste ragazzine che possiamo
aprire il pacco col fiocco perché c'è il
fiocco quindi è figo ende temi conto
della quantità di giornali in questo
pacco c'è tutta sta e pieno o mio dio
questa è la cosa più [ __ ] che abbia mai
visto cioè venire perché peluche no è
fantastica io ti aiutiamo ester
bellissimo sarebbe la versione
leggermente più adulta di questo
bellissima donna sono fantastici e dopo
che mario pupazzo abbiamo farvi nutella
pupazzo bellissimo un altro cat ma
quanti cazzo di che mario ciao ragazzi
ma che chiama quanti che mario mi avete
inviato c'è adesso ciò qua 4 cat ma non
ne bastava uno è grazie a un'altra
barbie nuda ma perché rinviate barbie
nude non ho capito che schifo state
facendo è come ultimo ragazzi abbiamo un
mac che cos'è questa roba
[Musica]
e cos'è sta roba mi spunta pure un
codino dopo questa questo coso bello è
questa scritta fantastica direi che
possiamo passare al quale risponde
perché rei che sto scattato sta
scendendo nel trash di brutto in inglese
tra l'altro trovato un commento in
inglese
why are you always wiring ex che
pronuncia bellissima perché indossi
sempre cappelli è un caso questo
comunque è this is a cage gold caylyn
dall indosso sempre che l'ue railways
where she indossa sempre cappelli amico
mio
translate di scippi cause ok this is why
i'm always no perché non c'ho voglia di
pettinarmi è questa petting myself era
per scherza non parlo veramente inglese
a questi livelli un po meglio di questo
che poi vi siete tutti in scena sheila
secondo 90 si ma se mi metto il cappello
un po meglio fa vi ci racconti la prima
volta che qualcuno ti ha riconosciuto in
giro per i tuoi video come hai reagito
se l'avevo già abbiamo lo ridico chi se
ne fotte praticamente è successo nella
mia scuola c'è un ragazzo che mi aveva
riconosciuto a cazzo ma tu sei quello
che ho visto su internet o mio dio tu
sei quello che fai digos e se il dj no
cioè io io io io fa vj tu fai il dj of
avg io ero più emozionato e ancora
adesso quando mi fermano invest ha
realizzato sono tipo emozionatissimo
perché io mi emoziono ogni volta anche
quando mi sveglio la mattina e dico
buongiorno a mia mamma mi emozionava
reagito dal ragazzo timido tanto per
cambiare quelli alla hitler
inizia il v12 si inizia il video sta
minkia inizia il video dicendo noi no
[Musica]
mai mai favi fire
scusate poi il ro ro ro poi risponde
favi credi che la fisica molecolare
applica il sistema stesso
ma secondo voi se io faccio la barba un
kiwi poi diventa più giovane ti capita
mai favi mentre dt un dito di vedere
delle facce strane che fai
[Musica]
sì direi di sì comunque ragazzine che
posso concludere qui con le fai non ero
chiesta troppa rella la domanda sulla
fisica
l'ho apprezzata per la favino vanno
ragazzi prima di concludere volevo
chiedervi facciamo siccome è finita le
isole show né già almeno è un'auto banda
ultime stavolta vuole serie horror
volete che io faccia dopo l'isola action
era giusto per curiosità per vedere che
cosa scegliete nonché ragazzine che
possano credere qui con i blog cosa sei
ragazzi se l'episodio è piaciuto e se i
baffi di hitler ei kiwi sono vostri
amici lasciando commento mi piace anche
a faccia di facebook come la di video
trovate la descrizione se non se ne
volesse tiscali ci vediamo al prossimo
video bello ragazzi